thank you
[Music]
being scammed
really
this one is road traffic accident this
is heart-wrenching
so I'll never forget that
will need you
I broke my kneecap badly lost 25 of My
Blood
when I was 17 years old I spent a month
in Zambia my church sent me on a trip
but the thing is I didn't actually have
anything to give but as a successful
businessman it's so great that I'm to go
out and actually invest in projects and
help the community and give back right
now I'm in beautiful Uganda I've brought
my team out I've got my man Benji who's
our guide and we're going to be checking
out some of the previous projects that
we've done a school that we've just
built are we going to check out some
Hospital works that we're doing some
water tanks and see what we can do next
here in the country of Uganda
good to see you in Uganda
we're gonna be heading down to the
school right now I know you've just got
off the plane but uh this is the school
that we've just built it's about two or
three hours drive from here and then
once we've done that we're going to be
meeting with the uh the local government
talking about the education curriculum
in the school and yeah we'll see how the
week takes us all right good
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look at me thank you for coming
thank you for coming
thank you for coming
thank you for coming
thank you for coming
thank you for coming thank you for your
warm welcome I think this is just a
start for bullabandi Primary School
we're very honored to be here I think
one of the reasons that we've done this
myself and my wife Amanda is because
when I was at school in the UK I've got
ADHD I've got dyslexia I wasn't a very
good pupil at school but there was one
school teacher that believed in me
called Mrs hey Smith you should tell me
you're going to be successful and her
belief in me made me successful and my
knowledge and my belief and I when I
came here to this school two years ago I
really believed in the school and I
really believed in the teachers and I
thought I'd want to back that belief up
by actually investing so it's a real
honor to be able to have built the
Samuel Leeds School main hall wow
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
very happy
for this wonderful time
a time that we are using because of
disciplined achievements
from somewhere else one thank you for
this year again I hope that is going to
be beneficial to this school and the
entire Community thank you that today we
have opened it but I commissioned this
call to you in the name of God the
Father the Son and the Holy Spirit amen
part of our goal is not just to build
school buildings but it's also to be
involved with the with the input and the
education system so it's so good to be
working with the government we want to
see all the children of the schools
financially illiterate and have basic
I.T skills and finance skills being able
to understand the difference between
assets and liabilities and Investments
and that's why we're so excited and
blessed to be here working at the
schools in Uganda and I just want to
remind you this is just the beginning we
will be coming back again and this is
the beginning appreciate the Ministry of
Education the government the head
teachers who've been at really
incredible also appreciate the builders
appreciate Benji the project manager
it's been absolutely an honor and we
look forward to spending the rest of the
week here as well thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
from the second the car pulled up I felt
the tears because they were all there
dancing and cheering the most welcoming
Community I've ever experienced in my
life when Samuel says you go to these
places to impact the kids and the
environment you're in when he says you
come back impacted it's 100 true I've
only been here one day and I feel but my
life has changed
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's so great to be here today the big
celebration seeing everyone so grateful
for this building and I'm so glad that I
was able to utilize my skills as a
quantity surveyor in bringing something
that's going to bless so many people and
help so many people within the community
[Music]
Sam has credited me for helping him
achieve success in business and what
he's been able to show me is that with
the right energy and the right mindset
you can do things like this helping
people progress in their lives we
wouldn't have had the opportunity before
foreign
[Music]
last time I came here about a year and a
half ago this was all just land it's
just incredible not only building the
building so the kids can have a
classroom but also partnering with the
Ugandan government they've allowed us to
have a say in the infrastructure of the
curriculum so that the kids can be
financially literate that to me is huge
we don't even teach that stuff in the UK
and I think the true thing that breaks
poverty is education so ridiculously
excited
foreign
ly overwhelmed I'm blessed yeah just
speechless
[Music]
foreign
I really believe that Africa there's a
lot of opportunity for investment and
development right now I'm investing in
Ghana we're doing apartment service
departments that are being built as we
speak I'm a partner in that where we're
standing in Kabbalah this will be a city
one day you can buy a land like this for
like three four thousand pounds imagine
how much it's going to be in 10 years so
as long as you can get cash flow from it
I think the potential is huge here in
Africa so I'm excited about not only you
know yeah doing schools and giving back
and helping the community but also
actually making money and then using
some of the profits that we're making
from development and from Investments to
help the local community you know it
just it's a win-win and it's fun and I
love being here
please
and Samuel this is my wife Amanda we're
thinking if we can build a school
through our charity maybe we could
potentially build and also make some
make some money and we were just
interested in what the development
opportunities are in
Uganda for example this was a lady from
UK she wanted to develop a place in the
company here yeah it's not big she's
just built high let me guess how big it
is I'm going to say that is maybe one
third of an acre yes
I just want to work out the costs so
this whole thing cost how much to build
I'm gonna guess yeah I'm gonna guess
they're 24 units let me guess
that I'm gonna guess that that much
to build hey that's the attack sorry is
that correct yes
Amanda Amanda taught me how to cost
things that's how I can just see and
just go bang bang bang I learned
everything I know but from Amanda for
example 100 for the land 100 million
yeah yeah can you put 180 for
construction yeah and you sell it at
500. what 600 or 600. so how much money
is that that's a good profit so
basically you double your money yes how
realistic would it be to find a deal
like that can you get achievable and
nearly a way you can get that yeah see
if I could find a deal like that I'll be
down I'll be down
[Music]
it turns out that it's very difficult to
buy stuff in Uganda solely as a foreign
citizen so unless you're Ugandan it's
not easy to buy a piece of land and
build on it so one of the best
strategies is to partner to joint
venture some of the most lucrative
opportunities are finding developers or
people that are trying to be developers
that haven't got the fund to finish
their existing projects so this for
instance this is going to be a hotel
and the guy that bought this land and
started the build is run out of money so
this will be a perfect opportunity for a
potential joint venture there's a lot of
due diligence that needs to be done in
terms of does he actually own the land
there's a lot of scams that go on out in
out in Uganda also making sure that the
build cost what's it going to be because
this area is so remote the dude that
started this project he's bought this
land and started it with the money that
we gave him because we came to Uganda a
couple years ago we did a business
workshop and we gave out small business
loans literally like 500 pound a
thousand pounds small loans
and Charles with the Monet has bought
some land so it's a really good story
I'd love to partner with him but a lot
of videos to do first
I bought this line so this was about one
thousand three hundred dollars so all of
the money went towards this land yeah
okay so we are using it for glowing
clothes so how do you make money from it
sorry how do you make money from this
uh we don't make money from this because
we glow food Club yes
then food crop we just consume okay with
our children yeah simple yeah
[Music]
there's not many Building Materials in
here there's actually beds it looks like
someone's actually living here don't you
think it's just the sofas kitchenette
beds yeah so Charles yes
um how did you afford to buy the land
sorry how did you afford to buy this
land
um
foreign
that you bought with the money that we
gave you
um
the money you gave me no
what did you do with the money that we
gave you I bought another land across
okay yeah we have we have another land
across okay we have clubs
so you own the land
so we can check that on the land
registry
um
[Music]
what are you hoping to achieve from from
myself and from the team
and maybe to finish this house you want
to finish this house yeah to construct
this house for the children yeah but it
has to make profit yeah yeah if it
doesn't make profit it doesn't make
sense
so how will this make money uh no we are
planning to have some income generating
projects yes like chicken
because you have Market access market
right then you have rabbits there's a
demand here
but you could do that without this
how is this going to make money this one
yes uh actually
with time
uh we can
I rent it
did you notice that initially he said
it'll be a children's center
because he wanted me to invest as a
philanthropist I kind of sussed him out
and I was talking about profit he said
oh it's going to be a hotel
so which one is it is it children's home
or is it a hotel I'm out because there's
a lack of transparency on the table but
what do you think you're my guide
they told me
that it is Chelsea's home
it is his home not building four so it's
not it's not a hotel or a children's
center it's his house it's a house he
moved he's been here for one year now
now he wants to use you
to finish up his home his dream home
yeah as if it is a children's center
okay
we've been scammed
what did he say
well when I just came in
it did seem weird he said it was a
storage unit to house all the materials
on site but there's multiple beds
which you wouldn't need in here there's
a kitchen living here yeah
I mean look
I think the exact same thing let's go
okay
[Music]
Chris how are you feeling today a little
bit rough
um we have a dodgy stomach I've been to
the toilet five times already twice
outside in the bush I was um having to
go to the toilet just up there I thought
there was no one around so I checked and
I crouched and I was like this and a
little girl from up there came and she
was kind of face to face and she went
hello mister
and I don't think she knew what I was
doing I didn't know what I was doing but
um yeah it's all fun all good
[Music]
it's called bunioni Lake and this is
the deepest lake in the whole world
that Island we have seen whichever girl
to get pregnant he was a taboo in the
society
so they would bring the girl out of the
community and isolate them and take them
to the island to die from there because
they made a mistake to get pregnant
before marriage
so it was used as a punishment to take
people to be punished so it was called
punishment Island and is on a deepest
point of the lake bunioni
[Music]
thank you
what what's her name
she's called
This is between 90 and 100 years herself
now when she got pregnant while in the
village she was thrown the punishment
Island to be eaten by animals she spent
there four days no food no anything to
drink
until when a sailor man a man who was
sailing found on the island and picked
her and became the first husband
with her elder brother is the one who
took her there because they were more
powerful and instructed by the community
so when he took her there she stayed
there but when she got someone who
skewed her the brother came to visit her
where she were married so in other words
after that incident the family again
reunites when you get married what they
didn't want was when he was still single
and you came you get pregnant that's
when they didn't want how old was she
when that happened yeah she was younger
than this this girl yeah younger than
this one when they threw her
was there other people on the island or
just her yeah
oh that she was the owner one on the
island at that time and she was the last
one on the island the government they
organized themselves and stopped the
activity of taking the girls to the
island
you know how bad that
is
that Jesus Christ wiped out her anger
it ended then and she's a happy woman
now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
well that's it back to punishment
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow thank you
that she's one of the people that fetch
water from this tank she says that she
used to fetch water from down and she to
take her three hours to get to her home
now because the tank is here now she she
takes like 15 minutes to take the water
to her home from this tank
but before when I first came here in
2016 you know the walk that we just did
yeah which I don't know about you but
I'm knackered they would walk down
collect water from the lake which is
dirty get diarrhea like Chris yeah
bring it up lots of walks lots of walks
lots of dirty water now 30 families but
this is not the only one there's also
one further up and it costs around about
uh one thousand one thousand dollars
for per tankier and it's made of
concrete and it's big it'll last forever
yeah it'll last a long time
whoa whoa
[Applause]
hey hey hey it is a wonderful day today
[Applause]
okay today
it is wonderful day today
I've known someone since uh 2017 when he
got
an accident while on boat cruise so the
boat capsized and he injured his knee
during the process the patella bone was
injured oh it was quite serious it was
quite serious even during surgery we had
issues
yes we had issues these injuries were
very serious but we thank God he's fine
now
[Music]
yes government provides most of our
facilities in the hospitals but they
don't provide the
implants because most of them are quite
expensive what is an implant what does
it mean oh an implant
there are metals okay yes there are
metals I had an implant yes you had an
implant yes and I think I had to pay
maybe around about 5 000
Ugandan shillings
Maybe
can't remember no maybe five minutes
five million I think sorry yeah
so that you find someone if he has got
an accident
either he has to sell his piece of land
to get treatment and that means if he
has sold his piece of land then what
will he eat after
the treatment so he is going to go again
back to the streets
without what to eat
so when we get people like somewhere to
to help us
then you've taken a very big big lot
from us
because so many people are suffering
because they can't do anything
there's no money
but if we can get another building that
will be very good that would solve a lot
of problems that will solve a lot of
problems so the way we understand it
then is it's the the primary needs of
you right now is space
and implants
and you're the only hospital around
for five million people is it service
this hospital this is the main hospital
yeah yeah this is the main referral
hospital for those five million people
don't mind being people yeah
wow
this is world one it's an orthopedic
word where all the orthopedic patients
are managed this two two four this is
yes no no privacy we are seeing male
mixed with females and children so most
of these people have got fractures
mainly caused by trauma some infectious
that one has a chronic problem what
happened to him taking us HIV since
childhood and it's unified so by the
time he they brought him here all his
bones had got broken but because all the
bones are broken why because of the
drugs yeah the drugs they take kind of
reduce the bone strength so they are
prone to Breaking this one is road
traffic accident this one is infection
it's just the uh the young largest
he's a you know it's like after him it's
all feminine
he's got you know obviously a lot wrong
with him but you're still waving and
still smiling and I'll just I'll never
forget that
yeah
I didn't want to get upset in front of
them because it feels a bit insensitive
like they're the ones sat there and
going through all this pain
it was just heart-wrenching
the ward literally looks like something
that might imagine in the 60s or
something the beds don't even look clean
enough for a patient to be sitting in
who's got wounds
oh it's just horrible
but I'm really glad that we're in a
position where we're able to help
so I've played a thousand pounds which
is uh four million wow
[Applause]
they've pledged 2 000 pounds which is 8
million
oh my God
very much
so what I'm thinking is if we had a new
hospital award every six months when my
team come to Uganda we could show them
the ward and we could ask them to make
donations for implants okay so I would
like to officially confirm I am happy to
donate a walk wow
[Music]
I think somewhere is not a Ugandan but
it has come all the way from UK to say
thank you may God continue to prosper
him and protect him for us
[Music]
Jesus makes me feel
eyes
so nice
so nice Jesus makes me feel so nice
God's love is like a circle no we don't
sing that one
[Laughter]
of the things that we're really
passionate about doing through the
Samuel Lee's Foundation is building
schools where we can then have thousands
of kids thousands of students that are
all learning and growing their education
which is ultimately going to help them
when they're adults because the children
are the Next Generation so we're just
looking at different spots now where we
can partner with the government and they
can donate the land to us we'll build
the school and then we've got all the
infrastructure and we can partner
together to really make this happen
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
a check or giving overseas but unless
you're actually there on the ground and
familiar with the needs you might be
given to something that actually is not
very sustainable like for instance in
this room here they've got 27 computers
and these computers have been given from
an overseas charity to the school but no
one knows how to work the computers for
a start they've got very limited
electricity so they can't really they
can't really use them even if they knew
how but even the head teacher doesn't
know how to use the computers the people
that donate these computers God bless
their hearts great lovely thing to do
but they've been you know they've been
here these computers have been here for
seven years
foreign
schools
[Music]
right now we are in the bush we're in a
really remote rural part of Uganda just
outside of Uganda and we're in a meeting
and we've currently we've said we're
going to be here and there's 70 parents
that are here with hundreds of kids and
they're basically saying they've got all
this land owned by the government
can we please build a school they need
classrooms the government have said we
can do it the government have said that
they can donate the land to us if we can
build the school so we'll see what
happens but these kids next time I see
them hopefully they'll be in school
uniform
are you ready you're down for that kids
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
to help
put your base off
I think it's a case of
you want to donate the money to the
place that's got the most need I'm
feeling already like a bit guilty for
not being able to help every school if
you get that or not how do you like have
you heard the story of the man the man
with the starfish huh
basically there was there was a load of
starfish that were all taken from the
sea and the Sea took them onto the sand
and then the sea went back in but left
all these starfish on the sand and
they're all dying and this guy saw the
starfish all dying and came down and
picked one up and throw it back into the
ocean live again and take another one up
and throw it back in and this guy
walking past said what are you doing
there's thousands of them you're not
going to get them all back in the ocean
and he picked one up and he said yeah
but it all changed the world for this
one
throw it back in so you can't change
every school every child but when we do
something like we did when we built that
school for those kids the whole world
has changed and there's a lot of needs
in the UK across Uganda Africa Europe
that you can just do what you can do and
my attitude is if you can just leave the
world a slightly better place than you
found it then then we've done our job
once we've seen all the schools we're
going to have a debrief and say which
we'll have a discussion about what we
think we should do we'll go through our
budget we've put aside um 25 000 pounds
for the for the next project
if you wanted to chip in a little bit
extra might be able to do a bit more
we'll see how we go yeah great awesome
[Music]
uh your brothers yes
they're starting to school
and they've got big vision
so we're here to help
when did you set up the school year 2006
oh wow long time
you had the vision of building that
whole that way as we're making here
bricks there and the children age-wise
what's the who's the youngest pupil and
the oldest people it's from four years
that is the necessary section in four to
five years now this year is 16 years so
who's the oldest where's the 16 year old
[Applause]
how many how many teachers do we have
here teachers teachers we have 15 15
okay that's good yes ask you a question
what was it that gave you the vision and
the idea to start a school in the first
place as I've told you we are teachers
we are teachers and this government of
Uganda isn't like your government yeah
getting a job is the government is not
easy so we have to sit together as we
group ideas play my teachers so we can
study our own things that we can teach
Disney Learners such that we can develop
from there such that when you get to the
government jobs will be ready so we have
the vision that in case we finish with
this Primal as we are teacher Educators
good secondary we go actually the vision
is high because we want to go up to
highest level um you know you said to me
earlier you said how do you know I don't
know about you but there's something the
gut says this is the one it's got a lot
of kids in the area yes we've got the
potential to buy a lot of land so we
could buy land we could build a big we
could make this the best school in the
area and I think as well the part of the
way is the vision
from the people around like the guys
that have tried to do a school here it's
not really working
but the vision they haven't got the
money they haven't got lots of things
they've got the infrastructure but their
vision is huge and he's been going since
2006 you know he's yeah he's committed
he's committed and also the government
will be very open to assist him yeah
with what we're doing here haven't got
them on side yeah it literally looks
like it's going to fall down it's so
unsetting look at these bricks though
look out and uh and uh feel like this
part of the building just needs to be
knocked down completely it does and just
I want to start from scratch yeah I
think you just knock this down it was a
good effort but it's just it looks as
well because you know what happened
there you know what the story was it was
the parents wasn't it correct the
parents built this because they were so
desperate yeah but because the parents
built it it wasn't done properly
Builders it's just Fallen it's just
falling down year by year they've been
trying to get the government to fix this
school building for 12 years
12 years they've been trying to get them
to do something and it's just slowly
getting worse and worse yeah it's not
safe it's just not happening you can't
even use the blackboards No No toilets
no nowhere to wash your hands
and mostly kids haven't got shoes on so
and you can see that from the foot marks
so imagine what this is going to do to
your
your feet constantly it's not there's
not a school within how many 27
kilometers so this is the first school
within 27 kilometers very remote and
there's 100 kids like what I know it's
insane what to be honest the school
needs help
it's I think it needs a lot of money
there's a lot of money yes
because the building is stretched yeah
and every every room is needed
because there's a main hole in between
so there's no building a separate main
hall
I think we need to pledge to do this
school because this one is badly bad yes
and also the Stu the students the pupils
are dwindling so we need to do something
fast yes so in total maybe 50 000 our
most
let's do it
[Music]
so good day in terms of pledges we've
got a lot of other work to do here
you've seen a lot of needs pledges time
Chris Darcy how much are you guys
pledging to put in
yeah yeah
ten thousand ten thousand ten thousand
hold on hold on is that pounds or
Ugandan shillings
[Laughter]
appreciate your generosity amazing Tony
how much you're pledging brother well
I've never been outdone by Chris so I've
got to say
1001.
[Laughter]
how fantastic
[Music]
the world
it's incredible
amazing
[Music]
good morning beautiful guys
[Music]
it's been a good week fantastic
do you see that bridge over there we are
going to be bungee jumping off of it no
way
so I'm gonna go first are you up for
bungee
are you down for this Chris
medically exempt
I'll be medically exempt
oh my gosh I've done this will be my
10th bungee jump now but the fear of
jumping off of the bridge
is extremely scary but when you actually
jump
it's not it's actually quite peaceful
beautiful experience and I think it's
very symbolic of everything in life that
we're afraid of so
let's go
all right fine four three two one
[Applause]
oh my God jeez you'll be fine
Chris if you die all right I'm not doing
this for you yeah you can please okay oh
my God
hello I am
we'd like to do some bungees please
okay
what are you doing apparently if you're
over a certain way you don't have to do
it yeah
I tried using the bricks to weigh myself
whoa
foreign
he's coming yeah
[Music]
come on Chris
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
yeah
you did it but I thought it was a nice
one
the first time in Zambia in Africa I saw
that there was a bungee jump above the
Victoria Falls a massive big drop and I
remember thinking no why would I ever do
that jump
the whole run-up was absolutely
petrified I was scared I was afraid I
was almost in pain even though I was
just sat there having my feet tied
everything within my being was telling
me don't do it this is dangerous this is
scary it was a horrible horrible fear
and the second I jumped the very second
I started falling down from that bungee
jump it felt like Bliss like paradise I
almost felt like I was floating it was
fun and I realized in life it's the
exact same when you're doing things in
business the thought of it is scary the
thought of it is nauseating
but actually when you just crack on and
do it
absolutely fine yeah
[Music]
yeah unbelievable what did you learn
to [ __ ] do it yeah just do it just do
it the best things in life are on the
other side of fear and that's why not
only do I keep bungee jumping but I
always make my team bungee jump as well
because it changes them and they come
back from Africa a different person
someone ready to conquer their fears
face their fears Feel the fear and do it
anyway
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
come on
[Laughter]